jc mejia he's got all of the pitches to
be very successful mid 90s with his four
scene fastball and his sinker cedric
mullins at one point in the baltimore
series he had nine consecutive hits in
nine consecutive at-bats
and mullet sprays this one to shallow
left field that will fall cedric mullins
just keeps on hitting cleveland pitching
an o2 count no matter a lead off single
for cedric
here is anthony santander the switch
hitting right fielder banding
left-handed
swinging in a missy struck him out with
a high fastball that might have been
just a straightforward seamer just a
little elevation got him to swing
through it two down for dj stewart 42
of his plate appearances this year have
ended with a walk a strikeout or a home
run 2-2 offering
swing and a miss he struck him out with
a slider to end the inning
a couple of k's for mejia the indians
are coming to bed kramer looking for his
first win of the year on five with a 687
era this is his tenth start these are
hernandez who went three for 12 against
the orioles with a home run
but just when you were hoping he was
going to take off in the month of june
he has really struggled but maybe that's
the sign that he'll get hot
ahmed rosario seven game hitting streak
there he goes
and that little foul ball okay
oh maybe it got him on the wrist but no
i think he's got the bat
or unless he's telling him it hit him in
the hand
is he telling the dugout
it looked like that's what he was
signaling it sounded like the bat to be
honest with you
hit it on his hand it hit right on the
knuckles yeah i think they want to check
well i think tito's asking him can can
they just take a look at it i don't know
if it's a challenge you know what i mean
he gets first base
it'll hit him go to first all right
so it pays off
now i wonder what brandon hyde's arguing
here with sam here you really can argue
you're not supposed to i don't think who
knows he's gone he's gone already oh he
got ejected yeah because you're not
allowed to argue a call
mr
threw him out of the game and now
brandon hyde is going ballistic
but he's going to get his money's worth
now
no score tribe with runners second and
third nobody out
but he did and jose hits it high in here
the left fielder falls down everybody's
gonna move
a run will score it's one nothing
cleveland and ramirez goes all the way
to second because stewart inexplicably
tried to throw it all the way to home
plate i mean he just slipped and went
down you know it did rain but that throw
there is beyond me why it goes to that
is to go to second on the throw
rosario's at third here is
eddie rosario
eddie rosario sends a high fly ball deep
left field stuart beck on the track
makes the catch up against the wall
tagging coming home is rosario ramirez
in the third it's two nothing cleveland
bobby bradley with three on the right
side of the infielder hugging the cut of
the grass though
bradley shoots it in the left field on
the no two pitch and it's three nothing
cleveland oh bobby bradley
he is five for seven
with runners in scoring position on the
year
and the indians have put a big crooked
number on the board here in the first
stewart struck out to end the first
orioles down by three
here's dj
and a ground ball from stewart right
side gonna be a tough play at first
mahia covers gets the outer run scores
with mancini and santander goes to third
three-nothing lead you walk the lead off
guy you throw a double and then dj
stewart rolls over one and you get
yourself the first run
and a ground ball nub to mejia he's not
going to have a play at the plate so the
orioles get
successive runs on groundouts for stuart
and then galvez and it's three to two
jose ramirez with cesar hernandez at
second base and one out
and the 2-2
is ripped to right field it's going deep
it's over his head it scored hops the
wall around third scoring is cesar
hernandez and captain clutch delivers
yet again
he can't throw the fastball by him
inside he got ahead of him when the ball
fastball was away early in the count
a couple times he tried to go back in
there and he was able to follow it off
but this time he didn't miss it he's
seen enough pitches the indians lead the
orioles 4-2 baltimore batting seventh
inning runner at first two down for
pedro severino dj will be on the run
three and two two down
that's in the dirt
and semorino works his way all the way
back from owen two
to give the orioles a couple of base
runners gonna bring franco up to the
plate with a couple of men on base a
lengthy inning for shaw the orioles
hoping to extend it
and franco hits a ground ball through
the right side the orioles will do just
that steward coming around third to
score and bring the o's within one a
pinch hit single to bring home a run
from michael franco veteran hitter
veteran approach
veteran result
so bradley zimmer to face
tanner scott
who throws in the mid 90s fastball and
slider
zimmer gets under this one to left
and that's where dj stewart is
as franco drove in
last orioles run in the seventh 1-1
slider
cued up the third base line it's a fair
ball severino's got it throws to first
for the out brings up ahmed rosario over
two hit by a pitch he scored back in the
first and that was a key play
rosario to second
orioles going to see emmanuel klasse in
the ninth down to run it'll be galvez
mount castle
and now the indians three outs away from
getting game one of this four game
series if emanuel clausse can come out
and get his tent safe freddie galvez
is over three
swung on and missed boy that was down
and in and no chance yeah that was
filthy
mount castle one out of three
spawn out of misty blew it by him
back to back strikeouts for class a
and there are two down in the night
watch the cut on this one too
that's just
[Music]
pedro severito over two with a walk
steps in one two
[Applause]
crowd ball to short
rosario
now it's official book it the indians
take the series opener
4-3 is the final